we had the red wedding in season three
what do you make of that what was your
reaction I couldn't believe it I don't
like that's all how could he do it
Starro oh my god I remember watching it
my flatmate and I knew what was going to
happen and I was kind of like seeing
that behind him just watching his
reaction it was yeah it was pretty
really really good it's pretty intense
and there's that there was a lot of
tears and a lot of gasps having read the
book and knowing it was going to happen
even then reading it it was really
shocking and it is very understand a
whole lot of stuff on the web of people
who didn't know was coming seeing it
coming and it was played so beautifully
so horribly and so feelingly I heard a
reaction a lot of people saying video is
coming but they didn't want them to
happen they're kind of welling it not to
happen please don't do it but they did
it yeah we've killed some extra people
to the killer's wife it's just so
remarkable that even having been well
aware of what was coming
you know I'd read the script I knew
exactly what was happening
it was still just really really shocking
I wasn't really ready for that and it
was amazing it was amazing acting I was
actually in Madrid at the screening so I
was with about 800 sort of shocked and
awed Spaniards
and when I saw that episode and I
thought it was a clue it was done
brilliantly I thought it was handled
really well you know really kind of took
a breath away
una and Michelle and Ann and Richard
absolutely smashed it as everyone did
you know it was suck it was amazing was
powerful out one Caitlyn knew she was
gone a song that it was heartbreaking I
mean apparently the the crew were crying
and I was not surprised brilliantly
brilliantly done Tywin is just doing
what he had to do
it's a feudal society that he lives in
and he has to retain his position and he
can only do that from being strong and
ruthless it was really hard watching you
know really good friends of yours they
dispatched a really horrible
Richard Michelle you know I know them
know them all pretty well it's not a
nice thing to see your friends getting
ready everyone keeps dying which is a
shame but that's probably what keeps the
viewers entertained and keeps people
watching and throwing books at the TV
episode but everyone's going crazy on
Twitter so I thought I'd do a little
reaction and then I actually watched the
episode afterwards it was kind of like
oh that was really unsympathetic because
it was really sad
what was your red wedding reaction we
babe actually it was more like oh yeah
yeah oh yeah obviously